j'ai reçu de nombreux messages de fans
de Beyoncé extrêmement déçu par
l'annulation de sa deuxième date de
concert à Paris alors il paraît que
c'est de ma faute je vais rectifier les
choses et le dire clairement je n'y suis
rigoureusement pour rien j'ai le dollar
mais faut pas charrier alors si le
producteur de Beyoncé a commis une
erreur est mis en vente des places à une
date qui était rigoureusement impossible
et intenable c'est de sa faute moi
j'adore Beyoncé je lui dis bienvenue en
Île-de-France mais la prochaine fois il
faudra prendre un producteur qui
vérifiera que le stade est disponible à
la bonne date
ouais c'est Valérie Pécresse
pas trop à ça
et Beyoncé tu aimes bien Beyoncé
j'écoute pas du tout mais ouais ça va tu
connais quoi moi je connais deux noms
[Rires]
alors c'est un vrai scandale je vais
vous expliquer pourquoi indiquer que
Beyoncé ne peut pas faire une deuxième
date parce que depuis 2 ans des travaux
sont prévus sur la ligne B du RER
notamment la station la plaine qui
dessert le Stade de France ces mensonges
tous les mois vous avez vous allez en
garde dans les RER et vous avez le
planning des travaux et elle n'aurait
pas pu elle qui gère tout ça pour des
passes Navigo qui coûte mensuellement 84
euros 10 elle n'aurait pas pu différer
ce samedi-là les travaux je suis sûr que
les employés vous ne prenez pas le RER
donc taisez-vous et c'est scandaleux
elle aurait très bien pu libérer la
station la plaine elle prive Beyoncé
qu'elle même est en colère des dizaines
de téléphone
et le producteur de Beyoncé a dit
Beyoncé très en colère contre madame
Pécresse mais qui est Madame Pécresse
pour nous interdire
franchement c'est scandaleux les travaux
peuvent tout à fait différé Géraldine
Pécresse pardon effectivement
franchement c'est la faute du producteur
de Guillaume
il avait qu'à savoir que ce qui était
disponible ou pas
alors là il y a peut-être 80000
personnes qui vont être pénalisées il y
a des millions de voyageurs qui eux sont
pressés qui les travaux se terminent
donc du coup ils ont décidé d'accélérer
les travaux et de fermer le Stade de
France les week-ends pour pouvoir
travailler le week-end et accélérer pour
que les millions voyageurs puissent en
profiter n'importe quoi
qu'est-ce qui est plus important un
stade un jour un soir pour que on puisse
assister à un concert ou le confort des
gens qui prennent tous les jours pour
aller bosser etc c'est un samedi vous ne
comprenez pas qu'on est ridicule aux
yeux du monde entier on ne peut pas
différé une date un samedi mais c'est
fou mais non parce qu'il faut que tu
comprennes que Gilles il y a des il y a
des plannings qui ont été mis en place
le samedi il travaille aussi les mecs
peut-être à des matériaux tu as plein de
trucs tu crois vraiment que l'intérêt
l'intérêt de du Grand Paris et de la
France c'est de s'asseoir sur 80000
billets de TVA rencontre l'argent que ça
ça fait perdre tu crois qu'ils vont dire
ah bah on va perdre 80 000 billets à 300
euros la place j'avais de la vie jamais
de la vie non moi je suis d'accord avec
qui déjà en terme de communication c'est
catastrophique elle s'adresse à Beyoncé
comme si elle était des galets égal à la
clash presque et là où elle est de
mauvaise foi c'est qu'elle peut changer
le truc ils ont fait pour Indochine il y
avait le même concert pour Indochine ils
ont reporté la date des travaux ils ont
pu faire le concert donc si elle pouvait
le faire elle aurait fait non mais
j'espère que vous plaisantez les deux là
parce que franchement ils font ça
justement les samedis les week-end pour
que j'aide moins les vrais gens et vous
voilà vous la seule chose que vous voyez
non mais vous êtes mais vous êtes malade
malade franchement prenez le RER vous
verrez voilà bien fait péter dans les
casques
[Applaudissements]